I noticed how so many people out there
that are successful smart educated
diligent but when it comes to putting
the money that they've made to work they
screw it up the mathematical studies are
conclusive the best investment of all is
literally it's the one exception to the
rule of I should seek out an expert to
help me get a better result financial
planners meet the
[__] they take more than they give
bottom line waren Buffet's been
screaming this from the hilltops for God
knows how long cuz these people are very
good at talking themselves up like oh
I'm the I'm the best around this will
help you you don't know what you're
doing let us do it like I can't believe
they're saying this [__] so it's
[__] when it comes to investing it's
so easy Once you know the formula it's
almost a blueprint for Success over the
last 100 years that type of investment
structure pays off every time here's the
deal Jordan Belford welcome to my
podcast thank you great to be here
you've got an extremely interesting life
uh you made tons of money then you lost
it and then you fairly quickly manage to
make tons of money again so right what
do you think it is about you that
enables you to capitalize I guess on
opportunity and make that kind of money
when the average Joe I would say can't
do that or doesn't think they're able to
do that What Makes You
Different so I think a couple things
number one I've always been sort of you
know that that that Ultra hardworking
entrepreneurial type great natural
salesperson right and those things
certainly are skill sets um and and and
natural born tendencies that have given
me an edge in the business world to just
so you know from a very young age I was
starting businesses paper RS selling
ices on the beach and then you know when
I got older I started starting formal
businesses right um but but in terms of
of of why I'm able to bounce back was
able to bounce back and and reent myself
and then come back stronger is that you
know business and making money has rules
and there are certain core strategies
that you need to know to start a
business or succeed at selling or
marketing whatever that might be and if
you don't know those rules or strategies
then you're typically going to struggle
suffer um and also your brains is
probably most people's brains are pretty
smart so deep down when you're thinking
about taking action maybe you're going
to start a business when you Play the
movie I like I don't really see myself
succeeding I don't think I'm like that
so you have beliefs that sort of say I'm
not really meant to be rich or I don't
possess the skills to be rich it's not
me so what happens is when you have
those types of beliefs it will stop you
from taking action so you won't charge F
when you should you you'll probably pull
back when you shouldn't so I I was
fortunate that um I have very empowering
beliefs about making money about about
uh my ability to create my own destiny
that you know life doesn't happen to me
I can create my own destiny um and I
possess very high level skills like I
know how to be an entrepreneur there's
rules to entrepreneurship I know how to
start businesses I know how to scale
businesses and I certainly know how to
train sales people and Market myself and
and my products in a way that gives me
an edge so so I think that is the good
news is it's a learnable skill that is
available to anybody so in the past I've
taught that I've given coures I've
released you know learning modules on
this stuff that have really helped
millions and tens of millions of people
around the world to sell more
effectively start businesses so that's
one side of the equation it's like you
know is becoming successful in business
and making money and living an empowered
life this book was about okay what
happens next what do I do with the money
I make how do I take that money and put
it to work the right way so it for me
it's a combination of like there's an
inner game of success your mindset so I
have a very strong success mind mindset
you know the ability to manage my state
of mind to me feel positive and
confident and clear and certain um and
then have a vision for my future and
then as well as ultra high standards
like I won't settle for mediocrity I
strive it's important to me to to
literally do I'm want to do the extra
work I think part of being successful is
learning or training yourself
conditioning yourself to do the things
you know you have to do to succeed even
when you don't feel like doing them so
those are just a few of the things on
the on the mindset side then again on
the outer game it's literally possessing
the skills like what are the Real World
skills you need to succeed as a business
person as a salesperson or even as an
employee trying to move up the the the
the food chain and a company so I
possess those skills and I taught to and
continue to teach those skills to people
and then the last piece of that is and
then what do I do with the money I've
made how do I take the money I've made
and really put it to work the right way
uh to ensure that I don't end up with
less than I started with or hopefully
you lose everything but but or a subpar
return hey quick break to discuss your
health which I do care about more than
is probably healthy uh because of how
sick I've been and I'm no longer thank
God if you don't sauna you should do it
there's basically definitive evidence
it's incredibly good for you it's really
easy and it feels really good I've been
using saos for years I first started Ed
when I was an anti-depressant withdrawal
and I've just kept using one for General
detox and Clarity of mind and Longevity
health I use Bond charges infrared sauna
blanket while traveling and at home it's
totally portable it works just like a
normal built-in bigger sauna by helping
you sweat as well as burn calories helps
reduce inflammation stabilize your mood
and deal with other symptoms like brain
fog and anxiety by helping your body
detox Bond charge is super easy to set
up and has free free shipping easy
returns and exchanges the reviews are
amazing my review of it is like I love
them super easy especially when
traveling go to bond charge.com MP and
use code MP to save 15% that's b o n c
g.com MP and use code MP for 15% off
enjoy the rest of this episode you
talked a little bit about skills do you
have you actually taken people who don't
have so you're obviously extremely
extroverted you're smart you're most
likely extremely disagreeable um don't
you think that you need you laugh don't
you think that you need that type of
personality in order to make it in the
business world because I I know CEOs
surgeons a lot of very high net worth
people kind of have that type of
personality and it it makes it easier
for them have you ever taught an
agreeable person how to sell and how to
become a business
person yeah the answer is absolutely yes
so so the system that I teach for
selling was called the straight line
that system can take any person I don't
care what your natural tendencies are
your talents it could take anybody and
turn them into a really effective closer
or Communicator um but again here's what
I always say listen I love playing
tennis right and I'm really good at
tennis and I've taken a lot of lessons
from World Class players uh and I and I
used those lessons in practice daily to
get like the level I could beat almost
any average player by a significant
margin right but put me on the court
with Roger feder I'm going to get blown
off the court without getting a game
from him no matter how hard I pr how I
try how much I practice how many lessons
I take I lack the natural ability to be
the best in the world the top 50 in the
world that's just not the way I am I
don't have that natural ability right
that's why I'm not a professional TPL
but I've really I've gotten myself
really really good so I can enjoy the
sport and beat most people well I'm not
saying that I can you know in three easy
lessons I could take you and make you
just as good as me at sales what every
bit is good at business or or or that
but I could easily and I have been doing
this for 30 years making people good
enough so that if you're being held back
it's not because of your ability or your
inability to communicate or close or
sell so essentially allows you to get to
a level that good enough is good enough
you don't have to be the world's
greatest salesperson to become a
effective closer and to be a great
business person you need to be good
enough so it's not about perfection it's
about progress and it's about getting
yourself to that level of being good
enough which is very easy to do for
anybody that wants to commit that's
number one number two is that one of the
successful things that entrepreneurs do
is they surround themselves with people
who possess the skills they lack so if
you and you do very very good at one
aspect of business and and yet you hate
the idea of sales or just communicating
or whatever Financial stuff right well
you might then want to survise with a
very strong sales type or a great
financial person so you bring in those
skill sets into your business that you
lack so you know you have to be at a
deficit that all the information you
need to train yourself is out there and
all the people the experts that you
would need to round out the skill sets
that you're missing are out there as
well and ready for the taking but just
to be clear there is unless you're
missing like some brain cells seriously
or you have some sort of impediment of
speech right you can easily get yourself
to be proficient enough at selling and
for that matter proficient enough at
investing your money so if you read my
book literally you you it's all you need
to to dab is you read my book you know
everything you need to know to build a w
c portfolio you don't need a money
manager you don't need that mutual funds
managing your money and giving you self
power returns you just follow the turn
keys solution is a step by-step in the
book and it's like inarguably the right
way to go about investing for the long
term that doesn't mean that you can't
have fun speculating there's nothing
wrong with that and I speculate so maybe
you want to take 5% of your portfolio
and speculate and buy individual stops
or buy crypto or invest in ventri apps
whatever that might be right that's fun
but you just can't expect that that's
going to be where your big returns are
going to come from maybe you'll get
lucky maybe you won't but you know
healthy speculation is fun uh it's
engaging and if you get lucky it can
work out very well for you um do you
have any advice for people who are more
on the shy side trying to get into sales
is there one thing you teach people
first yeah so I think that you know shy
is kind of is a a very broad term but
let's say people who are not they don't
feel comfortable it's not their natural
inclination to build rapport with people
or they don't like putting themselves
out there right I think that that this
the straight line what I teach the
system I teach right is very effective
for those because what it does it is a
lot of this do with beliefs they have
that they're not good at it so they are
not naturally good at selling or
communicating so you shy away from it
and and what happens when you learn the
straight line system when you when you
learn the skill set of persuasion your
brain cell say oh wow I I feel more
confident about this I'm feeling better
you it makes you more served so the
inner game and the outer game they they
they work for each other or against each
other for example if you have a if you
have a belief that I'm terrible at
selling and and I'm just not good at
this you know what you're probably right
probably suck and you probably shouldn't
be putting yourself out there selling
when you're terrible at it because
you're not going to get a great result
and all will happen is Will reinforce
the belief that yo see I do suck no
one's buying from me right so in order
to interrupt that cycle you need to do
something change your actual cont
compeny learn grow yourself learn to
become a better Communicator a better
closer once you do that your brain is
very small oh wait a second you know I
actually you know something now I didn't
know before I'm feeling much better
about this more confident and then they
start to feed on each other in a
positive way for example you know one of
the big mistakes that companies make
right or investors make here's a classic
one let's start with investors right so
you don't really know what you're doing
you don't know how to invest properly
you haven't read a book like MCM which
laats it out for you right and you go
out there and you use a stock broker or
the latest tip on Tik Tok or insta and
you get destroyed you lose 75% of your
money which is very common right then
you say to yourself you know what I suck
at investing this is not for me I I
can't do this [__] I I you and you
develop a belief that you're a terrible
investor the reality is is that it's not
that you're such a terrible investor you
don't know the first thing about
investing you're trying to do something
without possessing to the skill set the
only way to change that belief really is
honestly you kiss can't if someone's
like rahah raah go you just keep going
you get you're great you're awesome
you're capable of greatness you you can
close like an animal you have it within
you if they're just saying that to you
your brain's like [__] [__] like
no I actually suck I do suck so those
words those that that type of
motivation doesn't work because it
almost reverses on itself because you're
actually in reality no you're you kids
say you're great you're capable no I'm
not capable of GRA I kind of suck the
only way motivation works is if you're
simultaneously teaching people skill
sets that actually make a difference so
they're like oh wait a second maybe I
thought I sued in the past and I did but
now I know new things I have a strategy
I'm different I'm better than I was
that's how you break a false belief so
you actually make yourself better and
then you go out and take you be more
likely to take action bra will say you
know what wait a second I'm much better
now I actually knew this know this this
skill and makes sure more Serv and
suddenly your results start to improve
and then that Cycle Works in your favor
you get results that are positive and
you say oh wow I'm getting better and
you work harder and study more and it
feeds on itself in a positive way so and
that's exactly what I did with strand
where I you know took kids that didn't D
to clothes that were never successful
before and I didn't just say oh you're
capable of success you're great you're
awesome no they're not but what I did is
I told them that while I actually made
them great I taught them a skill that
fundamentally changed it made them
expert communicators so by doing that
and giving you the motivation those two
work hand like a onew punch you can
accomplish anything I always thought
that was something you had to learn
young or you needed some certain type of
personality I thought there were just
natural salespeople natural marketers
natural entrepreneurs and it was
difficult for some people to change
their mindset or even their personality
to get into that but you think it's
possible well like I said so I can
become a great tennis player but I'm
never going to be a pro I'm not going to
be so the point is yes if you're the if
you're like a terrible
Communicator awful selling I'm not
saying that I can teach you a system and
then in 30 days you're going to sell it
every bit as good as me no you probably
won't but what you can do very quickly
in fact is at a matter of weeks raise
your level up so you're good enough so
that if you don't succe it's not because
of your communication you don't have to
be an expert you only have to be good
enough in life good enough is good
enough combine with all your other
natural skills you have so that's the
goal is just to be good enough
proficient okay that yes you anyone can
become proficient unless you have
something wrong with you h i find it so
hard to believe that you can take some
of these people that are bad
communicators because I've met bad
communicators and teach them to be good
communicators is that is that just a
matter of becoming more disagreeable in
conversation or being more confident or
does it help I mean I suppose it helps
if you know what you're talking about as
well well number one is I I wouldn't use
the word disagreeable that s sort of
creates a picture you have to be an ass
or Comba that doesn't work well in sales
that breaks for poor with people so it's
not about becoming disagreeable it's
it's how do you get a Core across your
point to someone else in a way that very
quickly in the first you seconds of the
conversation they perceive you as being
sharp on the ball enthusiastic and most
importantly an expert in your field how
do you learn to come across like an
expert there's many people who are in
fact experts but when you hear them
speak you're like it don't sound very
confident they all you know right well
guess what that that's a problem of
communication like the that you know
inside you're you feel certain you feel
confident when the words come out
between your tonality your body language
you say you sound like you're a noice
right that's a correctable problem it is
it just is and I taught people all over
the world in every industry you could
imagine to become effective
communicators and some of them were
awful when they started and they very
quickly improve I'm not saying they're
as good as me or they're experts but
they're certainly good enough that they
possess enough knowledge to get whatever
they want in life so again it's not
about perfection it's about growth and
progress and being good enough and by
the way the itas when it comes to
investing
right it's it's so easy Once you know
the formula like I lay out a formula
it's so simple it's like any honestly a
five-year-old could do it so 10-year-old
okay and then you're really smart 5year
old but certainly a 10-year-old could
easily freaking my book and beat 95% of
the money manages out there and have a
massive portfolio waiting for them when
they turn 40 like it's it's really
that's the I it's easy to do it's just
that you have to just take the time read
the information open up a couple of
different accounts and it's just it's
like literally set and forget it's less
is more not more activity is less that's
the IR of the whole thing when it comes
to
investing do you find that some people
have a hard time simplifying complex
problems into just a stepbystep solution
which is part of the reason maybe some
people have a difficult time becoming
entrepreneurs because maybe when you see
a project you say okay okay here are the
main steps I need to do in order to make
this project successful and somebody
else might see a million steps and not
be able to sort it out for themselves
that's the certainly an issue but I
think even more common people take a
simple thing and try to complicate
it here's the deal when it comes to
overarching success
right many people when they're try to
become successful right they try to move
in multiple directions at the same time
they try to pursue four or five
interests or things they like and and
they're trying to go wide think that let
me go in five directories at once and
hopefully one of them will get traction
and work and then I'll start focusing
more on that unfortunately that's really
not a recipe for Success people that
succeed typically they they focus on one
thing and they put everything into it
and they you know leave themselves no
exit rants because they they make the
the the the possib of of failure so dire
so Unthinkable they give themselves no
choice but to they put them back to the
wall famous example is Elon Musk was
almost bankrupt back in 2008 right we
sleep you on the fact FL one day away
from bankruptcy right put every last
dollar you know on the line every last
inch of his soul on the line and there's
millions of those stories about people
who do that right and ultimately you
know it starts to work they succeed or
they fail and then they move on to the
next idea so I'm not saying if to you
never want to stick with a failing idea
but it's like one thing at a time first
things first not I'm going to go with
five directories at once and try to like
dabble and stuff and become successful
that way so that's the first thing is is
to be focusing on one thing and really
putting your all into one thing versus
try to like do three things or four
things at once because it makes it too
easy to give up when you when you
shouldn't give up and also you only have
so much you know Focus that you could
put and if it's being you know frayed
into five directions and the focus is
not going to be that powerful any One
Direction that's number one number two
is that yeah it's like there this a
really important concept is keep it
simple you know first things first right
you know you you look at a large
business that's making a ton of money
and you see all these employees and all
these different divisions and and um and
all these amazing things happening with
they're marketing their product well
they're doing interviews and they have a
brand they build around it and next
thing you know they're doing a podcast
or writing them and you look and say wow
so to be successful I have to like sort
of do all that stuff have to start a
podcast write a book do this launch
thing but that all came later like it
all like I'm sure I don't know your
dad's entire story okay about how he
became Uber successful and and and to
where he is today but I'm going to guess
it started organically where he started
giving some speeches and people like
holy [__] this guy makes a lot of sense
like I like to hear what this guy's got
to say so he gave a few more speeches
next thing you know it the speeches got
bigger and he was able to charge some
money for those speeches suddenly as he
got real Trac shows maybe I should know
a pro or write a book or do that in some
order and like it and it flow to this
pool now he probably has 15 employees
different divisions different courses
Mastermind events and this and that and
you look at his business now maybe even
as a vitam life I know I don't know what
that does but you see all these things
he's developed but it all started from
one idea of what thing he was doing well
so it started simple and small and I'm
going to guess that's probably correct
without knowing the real story you know
what so I don't don't think this works
for very many people but he always did
too many things at the same time always
so he started he's got a a couple of um
products like self-authoring and
understand myself it's just an online
products those did did nothing for 20
years they were online and available
they work really well but there was no
marketing and nobody knew about them for
20 years so they were there he had his
clinical practice he was a university
Professor he wrote books um and then he
had
which was just to put his his like
classes online and then randomly those
started getting picked up and then
that's what made the products successful
and then that blossomed into a podcast
so you're partly right there but he was
always like at one point he became a pro
at picking out valuable paintings so our
house was suddenly filled with hundreds
and hundreds of like Soviet Union
paintings because that was part of what
he was doing with his time but he was
he's always been I don't know hands in
12 buckets which is just right it's a
lot which will which by Pro my guess is
he probably could have been successful
five years earlier if he had his hands
and a few less
buckets but it doesn't matter the point
is is that is that it was one thing one
aspect of his business started to work
big and gave him traction and from there
he started building on that and building
on that and then suddenly the other
things flow through after okay so at the
end of the day again it's it's it's a
very common theme among success whe
whether it's in business or investing in
the stock mark it doesn't matter it's
literally less is typically more having
laser guarded focus and not over
complicating stuff when when it when it
comes to investing right I'll tell you
what people do they over complicate
trying to beat the market trying to TA
the market uh what's the next shiny
object is it nfts is it the latest uh
point off frame when the fact is simple
proven system for investing I'm going to
land but it's so easy you can't help but
succeed at it same thing goes for
business and in life it's a simple like
you first things first laser guard
position and ultimately things start to
you know before you know it you might
have five or six things doing really
well um you you spoke a little bit about
having people around you that can make
up for skills that you lack what about
knowing when to fire somebody like when
do you let somebody go how do you
decide so it's a good question right
and so this is why it's important I
think to to not if if you're not
naturally good at something you should
still spend some time at least bringing
up your level as high as possible don't
be one of these people I don't like
anything with computers I don't know I
don't and this because it makes it very
easy for people to [__] you right so
you want to have some basic
understanding of all aspects of your
business right but you know I'm a big
believer in letting um letting
performance speak for itself and not you
know buy into words words talk is cheap
performance matters so as a business
owner you know you need to be tracking
performance of your this is what this is
what really entrepreneurship is about is
you know is finding the right people
delegating Authority in the right way
but not just ding it ding out recklessly
or aimlessly it's like finding the best
people and then watching them having KP
guys keep performance indicators in
place and making sure that people are
living up to what they say they're doing
and not getting into this situation
where you start to believe that
someone's indispensable I can't live
without them no one but you Mr or Mrs
business owna is indispensable anyone
can be replaced so you know you and and
and the stronger you feel internally
about your own skill sets that you like
you know especially the ability to go
out and hire people like that's a sale
like selling people persuading people to
come work for you to buy into your
vision your dream your your vision for
the future right so you know that's why
I think for all people they should
become at least proficient at selling
and communicating because it cuts to
everything negotiation all aspects of
business but you you don't want to be
that person that that thinks that each
or any one person so important that you
can't afford to let them go that's
[__] okay you need to be watching
the people that you delegate to having
key performance indicators looking
tracking the numbers tracking the
results and remain accessible in your
business and if something's not working
you give someone a warning the second
one and they're gone and you replace
them okay so it's like three chances
basically some maybe two two and okay it
depend it depends how listen it depends
how egregious it is sometimes you know
someone will do something that if
someone's I'll tell you even as bad as
incompetence is negativity I have no
room no tolerance for negative people in
my business if someone is negative it's
like cancer you got to cut it out really
really fast so so I would not even if
someone has talent and doing it show
they're negative they're not Towing the
company line Rebel rousers out so you
want to get rid of those people as
quickly as possible and also is remember
some of this is to attract away people
you also have to move to compensate
people and make people feel like
Partners so it's like you know it's
there's nothing wrong with having profit
sharing plans and incentivized bu to
feel like they're treating it like it's
their business as well it's a crucial
part of being a successful entrepreneur
and a I think also just remember like
the worst position you could be in is to
think or believe that you're being held
hostage by someone else like you can't
fire them because if you do you'll be
lost that is simply [__] it is not
true people are replaceable okay there's
no one that's so you know crucial that
they can't be replace especially they
have to do a good job because that's you
want to replace them right so as an H
you have to be willing to make those
tough decisions
yeah I I definitely fell into that trap
I was young though and naive I mean I'm
still fairly young and naive but uh I
definitely fell into that trap with some
lawyers we were working with my whole
family did where it was they're
indispensable for keeping things running
I was like what exactly do you do we're
not even sure and oh you wouldn't
understand what we do it's it's so
complex you don't have the business
experience like just let us take it from
here plus a large chunk of your money
they're gone now exactly but but they
were good at it y so there you go I mean
then lawyers could be the worst but
they're they come all shapes and sizes
in all uh different um you know facets
of the business you know people that you
know pretend to be great marketers and
you know they talk a big game but when
you really get down to what they're just
all doing is delegating it out to
someone else um you see it in
manufacturing you see you see it all
over the place so again that's what
makes a CEO or an Entre effective
entrepreneur is that you're managing
people and that means you know getting
honest with yourself getting honest
about your business and then not just
looking at results and intuitively
making decisions actually analyzing data
keeping track of numbers having your
your kpis your key performance
indicators and keep track of things and
if things are not working intervene
quickly don't wait for things to get out
of control things typically don't
improve by themselves if something is
going in the wrong direction you have to
intervene and take action to make it
better yeah that's for sure we learned
that too because if you let that go then
those people that cause tiny problems
end up causing extremely large year-long
problems it's amazing how Troublesome
some people can be no it's truly an
that's why like I I rather you know I'm
a big believer in trying to hire the
best People BET great talent and and and
pay them well don't try to sometimes you
know the person that will work the
cheapest is the most expensive person
you'll ever
hire hey everyone what do you think of
the episode what do you think of Jordan
bord I'll give my response to it and
general impressions in my upcoming Q&A
but I'd like to hear what you guys think
too if you haven't tried my hangover
supplement it's available at Fuller
health.com I just had someone DM me who
doesn't drink often she just has them on
hand and the bottle has lasted her for8
months cuz it's massive so she's on her
second bottle now these are not to
encourage drinking they're to encourage
not damaging your brain as much if you
choose to drink the impacts are
incredibly noticeable in reducing
hangovers plenty of peer review studies
are available on the website Fuller
health.com there's a 30-day money back
guarantee code MP for 15% off that code
I'm not going to keep around forever so
just so you know it's available at
Fuller health.com like I said we'll be
rolling out more supplements in the
future with no fillers just pure
ingredients that actually work how you
want them to you can sign up there to be
notified of new supplements we'll be
rolling out a sleep supplement soon
Fuller health.com enjoy the rest rest of
this episode let me know your thoughts
on it
please given you have a massive amount
of wealth and success
already why why bother with another book
you know WR writing is one of those
funny things to me it's something I I
hate writing I love having written and
um you know throughout my career this is
my fourth book now and I I never really
touched on the subject of investing
before um you know I focused on
entrepreneurship sales my life stories
but you know
I I had some things happen with members
of the family um that actually write
about in the book and I I noticed how so
many people out there that are
successful um smart educated diligent
but when it comes to putting the money
that they've made to work they screw it
up they they they make decisions that
are self-defeating they take advice from
the wrong people uh they chase the
latest story or shiny object whatever
that might be uh and because of that uh
when it comes time for them to retire or
buy a house whatever that might be um
they don't have the capital to do it in
a way that they would otherwise be able
to so uh you know from me investing
money in the right way meaning not not
like this a difference between
speculating and legitimate investing
with with the with the former being fun
and you can make some money with that
but when it comes to really you know
saving for your future and retirement
it's a very different sort of protocol
required so this book really was came
out of a a person experience from
someone in my family that lost a lot of
money um playing in the crypto in the
short-term trading world and I was like
you know what enough is enough I'm gonna
I'm going to write a book that really
shows everybody whether you're young
middle-aged or you know approaching
retirement the proper way to take the
hard earned money that you have from
everything you've done and like put it
to work the right way so you can truly
retire wealthy and with pride dignity
and freedom so that was the impetus for
writing the book okay do you get into
your views on on money managers CFOs
well maybe you don't have to put those
two in the same category but business
people in general coming in taking a
percentage of what you're going to make
and saying hey I'll do it for you don't
worry about it how do you feel about
those guys yeah well so you know
generally speaking I think it's the last
chapter I called the meet the [__]
instead of Meet the [__] right
they'll take on that they'll love that
movie right but I I I listen I think
that you know the problem is is that
we've been trained and conditioned to
seek out experts to help us solve our
problems eliminate pain from everything
whether it be whether it be your
psychology medicine legal the legal
world you know we've been taught
rightfully so that when you have a
problem seek out an expert right all
last wall Street's the one exception
where like the experts are going to
cause you to do far worse than you would
do if you just did yourself did it
yourself because um um the stock
market's a funny place it's like this is
is a vast um sort of entity that where
there's all the information on
individual stocks is readily available
to everyone at the same time so unless
you have some sort of edge like you're
you know working at Goldman Sachs with
lightning fast computers on the exchange
that are front running everybody in this
sort of you know Ultra shortterm trading
the average person that that tries to
short-term trade or the average money
manager that tries to beat the market so
to speak the S&P 500 after their fees
their commissions and the pressure
they're on to actually engageing some
short-term trading because you want to
see if you give your money to a money
manager you expect to see them do
something not just oh I'll buy the S&P
500 an index right so what happens when
it comes to Wall Street and investing
experts work against you they actually
cause your returns to go down not up and
this has been proven like scientifically
mathematically with study after study
after study it's like the best and worst
kept secret at the same time that the
most Shire way to really build wealth
over time is through long-term investing
and you know buying something like the
S&P 500 which in a in a fun is ultra low
fees it's very tax efficient and
balancing that with some other
Investments as well but primarily that
and engaging in speculation with just a
small amount that might have some fun
hopefully maybe you can make a hit or
not but chances are you might lose more
than you make in speculation but this is
like obvious to people that really know
the deal on Wall Street but you know if
you turn on CNBC they'll have you think
that you should be trading back and
forth from crypto to oil to this stock
to one sector from you know AI into
Industrials and and and by the way it's
it's a disaster it doesn't work it it it
literally does not work and you would
fall between of those people that
actually end up making any money at all
and they certainly don't end up matching
the index fund so for example if you
look at massive studies I go through
this in my book by the way and all of
the mutual funds since the beginning of
time and and all the analyst
recommendations for individual stops
since the beginning of time do not beat
simply investing in the S&P 500 and
reinvesting your dividends and engaging
in this sort of
long-term investing that allows you to
have compound interest work in your
favor and there are a couple other
things of Jo explain as well in this
podcast that there's a really simple
term P solution that even a small amount
of money very small
$10,000 can end up as a seven figure
portfolio over time so that's the secret
to this is to not try to like outsmart
the market not try to listen to the
latest person on Tik Tok or um YouTube
or or Instagram say here's the three
hotest Penny stops or hottest tokens of
the day or and it's it's nonsense like
they're charlatans and and they charge
fees that and at the end of the day it's
really just going to separate you from
your hard ear money do you think the
people who are charging these fees do
believe in the cap their capab abilities
like oh no I am good at this I do
believe I can beat the S&P 500 or do you
think they know that this isn't going to
turn out well for their
clients they must know unless they're
deaf dumb and blind I mean because it's
it's like everyone knows like listen
there are some people there are some
people who can beat the market on a
consistent basis there are a few like a
handful in the world the problem is they
don't want your money they're got to
take your money they are managing
billions of dollars for their own
capital and they a couple of ultra
wealthy individuals that has a closed
Club in fact any of these so-called
hedge funds if they get really hot and
they are beating the S&P for a while
guess what they do they'll close the
town the fund give the money back
they'll trade for themselves so other
words there there is you it doesn't work
of course there are anomalies here and
there over time but generally speaking
when you look at all these mutual funds
and all these hedge funds after you
deduct the fees the expenses and the
extra taxes you have to pay because they
do a lot of short-term trading to try to
beat the market you end up going
backwards not forwards and what's even
worse is that there's um a very profound
difference between an 11% annual return
and a 7 or 6% anual return when it comes
to long-term compounding so something
that's compounding at 11% a year after
like 25 years it's going to be a massive
amount of money like it it makes a huge
difference if it's a 6% or 5% you're
nowhere in 255 you're still with that at
the starting you say how come it's not
working how come it's not working and I
think that's what kind of trips people
up is they they look at the amount of
money say okay I have I have $5,000 to
invest or 10,000 right whatever is
50,000 right how am I going to get rich
how am I going to really really end up
with anything substantial enough to make
my life also when I ready retire unless
I find the next apple or the next
Bitcoin or the next uh you know
Microsoft so they fall to this trap of
big that unless you have a huge amount
of money a 10% return is not sufficient
to get anywhere but that's not true a
10% return over time with compounding
becomes massive especially if you're
doing things like reinvesting your
dividends and you're making little
contributions along the way there's a
couple of things that you do and then
you balance that with some with some
Bonds in there as well as you especially
as you get older but this is like a
shire way to to have a a really heavy
portfolio I mean massive amounts of
money when you're older and ready to
retire it's not the wants to get rich
overnight that's not what this the stock
market will work that way that's a trap
okay so you know I wrote this book for
people who saying listen you know I I'm
working hard I have some money to invest
but I I want to invest the right way so
I know in then 20 30 years from now when
I'm ready to retire or you know people
are really retired as early these days
maybe you you want to be kind of cutting
back on your work right and be able to
enjoy life more right you're going to
almost be assured to have a
multi-million dollar portfolio provided
that the world doesn't implode okay but
it might implode along the way here and
there because the word there's always an
implosion along the way but even then it
doesn't matter you know over the last
100 years that type of investment
structure pays off in over the long term
every time okay so the S&P 500 that
seems to be stable enough even with like
the financial crisis in what 2008 even
with these these crises if you just stay
long term you can kind of see it
through so yeah so here's the way it
works right so in any given year the S&P
500 might go up or might go down right
generally for up what years has been
down but generally it could go up or
down so if you are looking to invest
with a a 12mon horizon you're taking all
your money and putting into the S&P
right you might lose that year you might
go backwards 5% or 8% in the worst year
maybe 25% even that's like the worst
worst year of all right but over five
years suddenly wait a second I'm I'm
actually the worst will have this I'll
probably break even over 10 years I'll
probably make a little money but once
you get past the 10-year Horizon there's
not one time in the history of the stock
market where that investment doesn't pay
off massively over the long term so I
think what people have to realize is
there are no getrich quick schemes in
the market doesn't work it that's not
what the market is meant for okay what
it is you take you have a business or a
job whatever you do that makes your an
income of some sort and you take the
some savings and you keep investing
month by month by month little by little
and when you do that using the strategy
that I lay out in the book which is a
combination of S&P and a couple other
things it it it literally it's like it's
almost a blueprint for success unless
the world implodes completely and goes
well and it doesn't really matter right
we're all screwed anyway so what does it
matter at that point but assuming that
that that the world stays generally like
still it's it's the world that we know
um you'd be hard pressed not to have a a
a really really successful portfolio
that's going to allow you to retire and
live the life you want and my way you
might if you're young right your late
teens or early 20s you want to be close
to it you'll have a mass amount of money
you'll be in your 50s so but but you
have to realize the Trap that you might
fall into is that in the beginning it
does doesn't seem to be working because
like I don't understand it's like
watching patri I may I'm up 15% this
year but I only had 10,000 now have 115
how does that help me yeah but it but
but that starts to change very quickly
as time goes by and you start
compounding your returns and the S&P
also has some really has some really big
years over time so you could just draw
like a map since the beginning of the
1920s and go back and any point in time
any 30-year period you're going to end
up really really well by doing that so
um Dad got quite a bit of money when he
stopped becoming a professor which is
just what happens when you basically
retire and that was immediately taken by
a bank in Canada and then we had a money
manager and it's underperformed the SMP
for forever um and the money manager
takes their fees and everything so we're
swap we're obviously we're getting away
from that but why is that the norm why
is a money manager the norm as opposed
to just investing yourself how did that
even become a position sure so so this
goes back and that's like you know one
of the things I talk about in the book
is something called The Wall Street Fe
machine complex like the milary
industrial complex which exists to
essentially feed on itself so it's a
sort of combination between Wall Street
Washington DC Madison Avenue with and
like you know the media and they create
this perception through Mass advertising
and mass brainwashing that you should be
giving your money to the experts in the
financial Community cuz they could do a
better job at managing your money than
you can now here's the AR that was
probably almost true well let's just say
managing your money yourself was very
very difficult before 1980 the the the
vehicles didn't really exist it didn't
exist okay and mutual funds were
charging exorbitant fees but but the
problem was the average person on Main
Street did not have access to
information in the same way you did on W
there was no internet right so you read
about some things in the Wall Street
Journal the next day yet on Wall Street
they're getting news delivered real time
to their desk and the Traders are one
step ahead right and you also had no
index funds you didn't have an S&P 500
Index Fund until 1977 so there was an
S&P 5 there was an S&P 500 but it wasn't
an index fund it was an index so there's
a very big difference between an index
and an index fund an index is something
you could just track so you say oh the
S&P or the Dow Jones is up 5% or 3% or
15% this year great so what does that
mean for investor you can't buy the S&P
you couldn't buy the S&P 500 or the Dow
didn't exist so the only way you could
then take advantage of the the General
stock mod is have a stock broker or
money manager that would that was had
the the capabilities in the in-house
research departments and the execution
abilities to go out there and buy these
big stocks and keep themselves informed
so yes and this 40s 50s 607s maybe in
the 80s it started to change right but
what happened is in the 80s with with
the beginning of vangard was the first
one to have a S&P 500 Index Fund it was
a gamechanging moment in the St game
changing like changed everything and in
fact Wall Street did everything they
could to suppress it they smeared
Vanguard they smeared the the the
founder Jack Bogle called him a fraud
they did everything they could to stop
this information from getting out to the
public and they still do it today with
like you know propaganda on CNBC it's
like a joke if you watch CNBC they'll
have you think that the best investments
are short-terms option and trading going
from this stock to this stock to oil to
crypto they they literally are out there
giving the public this sort of you know
false belief about what it means to
invest in the stock mark But in fact the
scientific the mathematical studies are
conclusive they're conclusive the best
investment of all is literally S&P 500
Index Fund balanced by a couple of other
things but primarily that right and
reinvesting your dividends making
frequent contributions small as they
might be or as big as they be along the
way and if you do that you're going to
blow away like 97% plus of all the fund
managers out there on a consistent basis
you can't Warren brother's got a great
say because I got to give give my money
to a bunch of blind monkeys throwing
darts at the S&P they'll do better than
than the money managers and usual they
can't compete with the blind monkeys the
problem is there's not a lot of blind
monkeys around throwing darts so so
essentially the S&P 500 Index Fund which
was invented by Vanguard right and now
it's like you know it became one of
those things where if you can't beat him
join him so now all the biggest you know
firms have their own version of that
whether it's black rock or Schwab they
all have and I in the book I go through
the top the best ones of all right but
that literally was like this almost like
this this it's like this shortcut to
beating the market on a consistent basis
and and what happens is that Wall Street
is like gets a bad wrap because here's
the deal wall Street's vital you know we
need Wall Street we need a strong
investment Bing arm to the country we
need to have a financial system that's
supported with people that sell bonds
and whatnot the problem is that's wall
Street's useful role they have been
their not so useful role which is to
convince the average person to trade in
and out of these instruments right and
it goes it works against them so by
essentially following the advice in my
book it's like the ultimate hack I call
the ultimate investment ha right because
it allows you to take the very best That
Wall Street does all the value That Wall
Street does create because they take
these companies public all these
companies in the S&P 500 they were once
small companies that became big
companies right and they went through
the investment banking um firms like
Goldman Sachs or morgage sing whatever
they might be right at the time some are
very old but what happens is is once
that value is created if the company
succeeds guess what it becomes part of
the index it becomes part of the S&P 500
so you're going to capture it anyway so
you have to play the game like if you
try to play wall Street's game and fall
into the Trap of trying to buy
individual stocks short-term trading
switching from sector to sector like I
it's just like I watch TV I'm like I
can't believe they're saying this [__]
like they they're making people believe
that because now that the economy is
slowing you should take your money out
of the industrial sector and put into
safer sectors like consua props it's
like what a freaking joke it's like
everyone know it doesn't work that's
history's proven that like by the time
you think you should be doing you should
probably be doing the opposite anyway
but the point is you don't have to even
deal with any of this short-term stuff
you have to take a
longterm view of the market let Wall
Street do all their work in creating
value taking companies public providing
them with financing taking D all that
stuff but you don't trade in and out of
things you hold the S&P 500 which by the
way changes the the the 500 companies in
the S&P budget today are not the same
ones that were there last year not all
of them every quarter the index
committee meets and they remove
companies that aren't doing as well
becoming less relevant they Chang this
the waiting of each sector so what you
know as the economy moved to more about
computer informational economy the SBS
made up more of those stops versus
industrial stops right so so like you
50,000 employees or 35,000 employees at
the
sended working every day tirelessly to
try to come up with these best 500
companies and then you have a company
like a Vanguard or whatever or like
competitors that have created this Ultra
lowcost index fund and you could just
buy that and you side step all the
[__] that Wall Street and the theme
machine complex is slinging at you and
by doing that you set yourself up for
massive success over both the short and
especially the long term that's the way
it works you know it's funny before you
ask question you said like you know you
know these managers they have any use at
all and I was like well no not really
the the truth is though is this there's
another side to this which is like
financial planners right which can be
useful in the sense of tax planning yeah
right of you know what accounts should I
use should certain taxfree accounts and
it differs by country so you know you
know the United States we have our 401ks
we have our Ira our raw th so there's
sort of these vehicles how do I minimize
my taxable income as well with when I
invested is a part of that and my stake
playing so for those sorts of things yes
if you have enough a certain amount of
money it might make sense to seek out an
expert for that but if they start to
tell you what you should be buying and
selling and have you engaging in
short-term trading or going from this
sector to that sector just run the other
[__] way okay because that's a a very
different thing than giving someone
proper advice on how to structure their
taxes and their retirement different
things you have to just kind of
distinguish that from investing advice
that make sense yeah yeah these people
are very good at talking themselves up
like oh I'm the I'm the best around this
will help you you don't know what you're
doing let us do it it's the one
exception to the rule of I should seek
out an expert to help me get a better
result it's the it's it's the opposite
if you're going to need surgery then I'd
suggest you go get like the world's best
surgeon right to operate on you don't
pick up a scapel and take a mirror try
to cut yourself open and do a
appendectomy it's probably not going to
end well for you right if you're going
to give birth go get a great you know um
Midwife or great you know uh um
gynecologist or obstetrician who's going
to help deliver the baby to make sure it
all goes well so you know commonly yes
if you get have your pipes break you
call plumber let the plumber don't fix
the pipes yourself right if the
electricity is not working don't try to
fix your electricity call the
electrician right that's how life works
except when it comes to investing when
it comes to investing it's the one
industry where experts take more value
than they give okay they take more than
they give bottom line they're unable to
give add value beyond what they charge
in fees commissions and whatnot and this
is a wellknown
thing on people on Wall Street who
really know the deal and I'm will to be
honest Warren Buffett's been screaming
this from the hilltops for God knows how
long and there's other great examples of
like you know famous studies that were
done where they you know they almost get
ironic after the end they'll say you
know maybe there are some money managers
out there that have this special ability
to uh to beat them off on a consistent
basis I just kids seem to find that you
know it's like right so like but even
there you know and there are a few out
there no doubt that do this but they're
not available to the average person
they're not taking your money they don't
need to they don't want to so they don't
that makes sense can you tell a
difference between someone who's very
good at say and just selling you on say
a course and a valuable course is there
any way to actually decipher that
through the internet or is it kind of a
crapshoot yeah well no when you listen
the good news is if you're really going
to do your due diligence and and you
know look at reviews and go online and
go deeper than the first page of Google
and you know really do you the thing you
don't hard do is go on to someone's
landing page watch five testimonials and
then say oh my God these people are
doing so well I can do it that that's
not enough research right you want to
really check the market to find out
which of these courses which of these
mentors is the real deal and which is
are full of [__] and you're going to
find most of them are full of [__] and
that don't have reputations but there
are some that have really good
reputations there are a few okay but
there few and far between um and you
have to do the research online if they
wrote a book um check out their book
these are these are like really
inexpensive ways to really find out
about real estate or already other thing
right is read their book if they have
one how are the reviews on Amazon or
whatever else do your research and and I
think it's pretty easy to to to smell
out the [__] okay what's real and
what's not and unfortunately most of the
time it's going to be [__] so um how
do you feel about these people I mean
you see all these get-rich quick schemes
online and one of them is take take a
small investment put it into property
rent the property this is all over like
Tik Tok and Instagram and then you can
bring in passive income by renting all
these multiple properties that you've
taken out loans on you know does that
does that act does that work or is that
just one of these get-rich quick
schemes well no I mean property
investment can be great right but
there's rules and strategies to the
property game you have to know what
you're doing now I'm sure like if you
look at 10 different products out there
they're teaching this probably you know
seven in completely full of [__] or they
just regurgitated information from
someone else that actually knew what
they were doing but if you have a great
mentor that knows how to to to find real
estate and whatever a rehab it or rent
it out you can do very well like that
okay but but the problem is that like
most of the people who were on there
Hawking their sares on Tik Tok or
whatever uh they're charans they they
don't really know what they're doing
they they just book on someone else's
book and they're regurgitating the same
information I AC my own sales stuff I
people take my stuff and they they
change one word and pass sometimes don't
even change a word they pass it off as
their own they're the greatest sales
Trader now right um some of them are
okay all right but but again um it it it
requires you you have to get yourself to
Be an Effective real estate person you
have to study the business get a great
mentor and watch it it's not like these
this this whole notion do St Al just lie
in bed press a button and become a a
billionaire property investor it's
[__] and a lot of these things also
that like you know there's like there's
parts of it that are healthy because
okay maybe they giving you some
information but then they always looking
to upsell you into the next level the
next level and so while the initial
information might be very sound they
will make you big but you real you
really want to find good properties and
hire us they are $10,000 a month into
our masterm program and blah blah blah
and suddenly you realize that at the end
of the day most of the profits that you
made a real estate being canalized by
the fees that charge you to be your
Mentor so you have to be very very
careful um because practically almost
everything you need to know about buying
great real estate you can find online
for free free programs free products and
there's nothing more paying money for a
product as well if it's very well
organized and very well done by a
credible person but there are a lot of
landmines out there for every legitimate
one of property is probably the most
legitimate one of all is is the same
thing goes for every other investment
it's crypto
oil um currency train those are all just
complete pieces of [__] I mean maybe one
works should probably not okay but you
know I believe real estate's a good
investment you have to just very careful
who you use as a mentor and to also not
over leverage because a lot of these
places are relying on on using massive
leverage and Leverage is really good
when the Market's going up and then it's
not so great when the market starts
dropping and you can't be finance and
and your apartment or your house is
empty and or Airbnb is getting cracked
down at a certain City before you know
it you're upside down all sorts of I
know in fact my camera man is sitting
there had the same exact thing exact
thing okay where he you know follow one
of these courses and he got into upside
down a couple things and working his way
out of it okay that's what you do but
but it's very easy to to lose in that
game if you don't know what you're
doing yeah are you ever concerned uh I
hear a lot on the internet I've talked
to a lot of people about how Vanguard is
I I'm I'm probably more on The
Conspirator conspiratorial side of
YouTube but how Vanguard and black rock
are slowly taking over the world and do
you think investing into their funds is
that morally
okay I think that's exaggerated someone
and I I'm obviously aware of that right
and I think that's you know what's
really happening is this so these these
large massive funds right Black Rock
Vanguard right um where when you put
your money there they're buying shares
on your behalf they're buying these
companies on your behalf right the index
right so and then you have the stop in
called what's called street name me the
stop is being held in street name so
theoretically they have your vote but if
you think that these companies are
literally just radically I I don't
believe it I think it's a mass
exaggeration that these companies are
radically pushing the woke agenda I
think the woke agenda is coming from
somewhere else and I hate the woke
agenda as much as anybody else but
probably even more than your dad I
despise it I think it's ridiculous I
think it's the the the the the death of
the world is the w i is just idiotic the
whole thing all right so I'm I'm I'm on
the same page with you on that stuff
right but I don't think that that is the
what's really driving it all in fact any
inkling of that maybe there was a moment
in time where they were like sort of
pushing this sort of you know you know
woke agenda more or this sort of you
know righteous investing that's falling
out of favor right now like everyone's
saying wait a second we losing our
shirts of this [__] Hollywood or whatnot
or Bud Light and people are very quickly
realizing now that you know what the
business of business is business not
social change right and I think that
that is dramatically falling out of
Vogue um and and I and I don't think
that is what's going to drive things in
One Direction or the other I don't think
it's that so I think that's a bit
overblown uh and certainly I think the
trend is going away from that people are
resisting now this social change through
investing so I think it's it's on the
way out okay I hope you're right I think
you are right it doesn't seem as cool as
it was in 2016 2018 it's not working
it's just it's just not it's not working
it was like an a failed experiment right
me how many movies have you see like
that I can't even watch them like when I
put on a movie as soon as I see some
walk confused [__] I turn it off I'm
like I don't want to I don't want to be
preached to and moralized to when I
watch movies or when I buy what beer I
buy me you're a beer manufacturer sell
freaking beer you know what I'm saying
now now if your if your business is the
walk agenda okay fair enough that's what
you do you're into the walk agenda
that's your core business that's your
people but the try to accus the general
businesses has turned out to be a
nightmare and it's Disney is getting
everyone's getting away away from it
right now because it's costing them
massive billions and billions of dollars
in law shareholder value that was very
interesting uh valuable information
about investing for sure and firing
people that was that was great and
here's a and here's a book by the way
the wolf of investors I believeing this
so much I believe every person should
have the benefit of knowing what's in
this book because as soon as you do
you're going to change the way you're
investing and you your St getting
results versus getting blown out with
the latest craze or whatever investment
craze is out there so it's a crucial
skill toab thank you again my pleasure
nice to speak to you
[Music]
m